Jeden Tag passieren auf der Welt unzählige
faszinierende Dinge und es ist wichtig sie
zu verstehen!
Und Wissenschaft ist die einzige Methode,
um das zu ermöglichen.
Und die steht bei Clixoom Science and Fiction im Mittelpunkt!
Herzlich willkommen!
Eine These, eine Theorie oder Hypothese gelangt
in unser Bewußtsein und dann wird sie immer
wieder überprüft und schliesslich bestätigt.
Und nur wenn sie dem standhält, dann wissen
wir, dass sie unsere Realität beschreibt.
Und das ist immer für die Menschheit ein
riesen Ding, wie zum Beispiel bei der Relativitätstheorie.
Alle ihre Vorhersagen wurden bestätigt, wie
erst jüngst die Gravitationswellen.
Und basierend auf diesen Erkenntnissen können
wir weiter forschen und gelangen zu neuem Wissen.
Das ist der Kern, das Herz unserer Zivilisation.
Wenn wir von diesem Weg abweichen, dann landen
wir wieder im Mittelalter und sind verheerenden
Seuchen, Naturkatastrophen und kosmischen
Ereignissen hilflos ausgeliefert.
Nur eines kann uns bewahren: Wissen erworben
durch Wissenschaft.
Wir berichten darüber hier auf Cllixoom Science
& Fiction in Videos aus allen erdenklichen
Bereichen.
Wir gehen an die Grenzen und zeigen auch die
Pfade ins Ungewisse auf.
Denn wir wollen unsere Begeisterung für diese
Themen mit euch teilen und euch so immer mit
den neuesten Nachrichten, den spannendsten
Ideen, Entwicklungen und Studien versorgen!
Wir glauben fest daran: Man braucht keinen
Doktor der Physik um die Faszination von Schwarzen
Löchern, Supernovae oder Raketenantrieben
zu teilen.
Und man muss kein Diplom in Maschinenbau haben
um die neuesten Fortschritte des Hyperloop
oder bei Tesla spannend zu finden!
Die Berichterstattung über Wissenschaft,
Raumforschung, die Umwelt, Physik oder Medizin
ist für alle Menschen wichtig, denn sie lässt
uns die Welt verstehen!
Dafür steht unser Kanal und damit du, wenn
du uns hier unterstützt!
Wir freuen uns über jeden View, jedes Abo,
jeden der uns auf WhatsApp und den anderen
Messenger folgt und natürlich denen, die
freiwillig Beiträge auf Patreon leisten!
Dadurch werden wir unabhängiger von YouTube
und den Werbeeinnahmen.
Mit der Unterstützung auf Patreon können
wir durch eure Mitarbeit in der Redaktion
nicht nur noch besser herausfinden, welche
Themen euch am meisten interessieren, sondern
haben auch die finanziellen Mittel Clixoom
weiter zu verbessern.
Seid gespannt!
Es wird noch einiges passieren! Nähere Infos findet ihr auf Patreon, der Link ist oben in unserem Kanalbanner,
Oder einfach mit Patreon & Clixoom im Netz suchen.
Und an dieser Stelle schonmal einen riesen
Dank an alle Patreonspender, danke dass ihr dabei seid!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!